Hi, My name is Russ cox. I'm a member of the
Go team here at Google. Go has many interesting
features including built-in support for concurrency,
and a novel type system. But one of the main
reasons that I enjoy programming in Go is
that it's just plain fast. Most of my builds
when I'm programming take well under a second.
Let me show you.
[whoosh!]
This is the math package with implementations
of things like sine and cosine. It's over
a thousand lines of Go in about twenty files,
and if we build the whole package, it builds
in about 200 milliseconds.
We can also run the tests for the package,
which rebuilds the package including test
functions and runs it, and that runs in well
under a second.
[whoosh!]
This is the whole Go package tree. There's
about a hundred and twenty thousand lines
of source code and we're going to build the
whole thing. And the package tree includes
flags and regular expressions and the math
library and the formatting library, an rpc
package, a full parser for the Go language,
and many other packages and there: it built
in under ten seconds. And that's just running
on one machine, my laptop.
[whoosh!]
When builds are that fast, I can get a lot
done in a day. Go is a fast, fun, and productive
language, and we hope you'll try it.
There's more information and downloads available
at golang.org.